dans les yvelines aucun élu dès le
premier tour les électeurs héninois son
don tous appelés aux urnes dimanche
prochain
selon les chiffres fournis par la
préfecture l'union de la droite qui
avait présenté des binômes ump udi et
modem recueille 21,17 % des suffrages
la droite qui dans sa globalité arrive
en tête dans les 21 cantons
les électeurs sont assez lucide en
réalité ils ont su discerner que l'union
de du centre de la droite est une union
qui va vers l'intérêt général le front
national arrive en seconde position dans
le département avec 23% des suffrages le
parti de marine le pen qui arrive à
qualifier pour le second tour huit
binômes sur les 21 présenter contrat
rempli
c'est une super soirée parce qu on a
augmenté par rapport à l'élection
précédente avec encore plus de
participation donc encore beaucoup plus
de voix donc on est très content quand
on a progressé dans tous les cantons
dans le département le parti socialiste
totalise 16 89% des voix c'est loin
derrière la droite et le front national
les yvelines avait quand même très mal
voter ça aussi il faudra s'interroger
sur ce baisse de civisme dans notre
département
deuxième élément c'est le les divisions
à gauche qui nous nous oblige
aujourd'hui à nous reposer la question
de comment on fait travailler l'ensemble
des forces de gauche ensemble et puis la
troisième chose effectivement la percée
de dans l'électorat populaire du vote fn
qu'il ya des messages qui font entendre
et que on peut pas balayer ça d'un
revers de main sur notre secteur plus
précisément sur les cantons de trappes
montigny le bretonneux bord pas saint
cyr l'école ou encore plaisir
ce sont des duels classiques union de la
droite ps que les électeurs vont devoir
arbitrer
à noter que des duels union de la droite
fn seront arbitrés aussi pour les
électeurs c'est le cas à mantes la jolie
où le binôme de pierre bédier sera
opposé au binôme porté par cyril note le
maire fn de mantes-la-ville à
rambouillet christine boutin conseillère
générale sortante devra batailler aussi
contre un binôme emmené par le front
national ce qui peut faire la différence
pour ce second tour c'est la
mobilisation des électeurs dans les
yvelines ce dimanche 45 34 % des
électeurs se sont déplacés aux urnes ces
cinq points
de moins qu'au niveau national